Hey, so, one particular thing we need to
be concerned about is all the tracking
that happens when we visit websites,
they know where we're going.
So if you go to a website of course,
they will know that you're accessing
that website, but what about others?
So you'll be surprised how many other
websites are able to figure out that you
withered for
example www.NewYorkTimes.com.
These are tens of them,
I think at one point I read
50 other sites learn about the fact that
you are visiting www.NewYorkTimes.com.
These third parties are able to
do it because they're either
advertisements embedded in the New
York Times phase that you get back, or
they're the likes, the Facebook,
Twitter, and whatever other things.
And some of these things
we may not even see or
pay attention to, but
essentially, we pull some
bit of the content that makes up the
page from all these websites that allow
them to track the fact that we
are visiting New York Times.
So you can do what is called
third party cookie blocking.
So browsers actually, they allow
you to do a variety of things.
You can block cookies.
If you block cookies altogether,
then maybe you can't do anything useful
with the NewYorkTimes.com either, but
third party cookies blocking,
of course, protects you.
Blocking third party cookies of course,
protects you.
You can tell your browser that
you don't like to be tracked, and
in this case, the browser when it
sends some information to a website
would actually tell the website that
the user doesn't want to be tracked.
Whether the website honors that or
not is a different question.
Cookies are kept on your computer
to track your history and so on.
We can clear those and when the next
time you visit the website,
the website won't have this knowledge
of what you had done previously.
You can block pop-ups.
You can, there are other private
browsing sort of things that you can do,
browser modes that and
clear out any state that may be
built while you're using
a tab incognito mode or
even more sort of aggressive privacy
things that you can do to browsers.
So the idea is that
tracking is progressive.
There's some things we can do about it.
We don't know how effective those things
are but at least there are things that
you can do by going into your privacy
setting of your browser that you use.
And they're slightly different
across different browsers.
So So I'm not talking a great
deal about how exactly you do,
but I would highly encourage
you to explore these.